hello and welcome to a very special
episode of conan o'brien needs a friend
we're starting something a
series of shows something we attempted
once before i think two years ago right
called conan and the chill chums no no
well summer s'mores with conan and the
chill child yeah yeah oh
okay how's that obsessive compulsive
disorder coming
how's that
[ __ ] galactica syndrome
what a nice start
to a lovely summer day
we started two years ago uh with a
segment called i'm sorry
summer s'mores with conan and the chill
chums i think it began
um
when we had a conversation about s'mores
that's right uh i maintained that
s'mores blow that nobody really likes
them
it's a very flawed american treat
and just just
sony you've got to calm down a little
bit and then we'll get you can build up
to a rage but but for now
we talked about it and then it became
this series where we just it's just the
three of us chewing the fat
and what we thought we'd do is we'd
start in studio
and this would be the first episode but
then we would move
to uh an outdoor summer locale where we
can literally have a campfire yes we're
gonna have an actual campfire yeah and
so
i can't think of anything more exciting
than listening to people
who were inside
now being outside
and having a fire and i think that's the
kind of excitement we bring to people i
think there's a coziness to that that
people will find i agree i don't know
why you took tear to be a sarcastic tone
in my because maybe it was the look on
your face no not at all that's i had a
stroke a few years ago and it's made me
look very skeptical and like i've just
had a mouthful of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
anyway um you mean s'mores yeah so
we're going to be scared to talk we're
going to start that's the environment
i've always wanted oh my god so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start
today's episode
of summer s'mores with conan and the
chill chums that would be matt and sona
um
we're gonna start it here in our studio
our brand new spanking studio but
and and then we're gonna move to an
outdoor location are you comfortable
saying where we're gonna go matt yeah
and i think because i had big ideas
about us going to yellowstone
um i thought it would be really cool if
we went up to the like pacific northwest
maybe to the san juan islands
um i thought just some amazing maybe up
to northern maine up there in the in the
far reaches up near the canadian border
so i had all these great ideas and i
told you
um money's no object the sky's the limit
what did you come up with matt my
backyard
your backyard and i'm gonna pocket that
travel money oh yeah cause i did you did
ask for the cash do you ask for the cash
up front
no well we've got our i gave you six
hundred thousand dollars to work this
out and now we're doing it in your
backyard because i got a little i got a
new park bench
[Laughter]
uh we did talk about the fact that you
live on the west side both sona and i
live on the east side in the dinas now
that's two to two to one so we have a
lot of people listening who don't know
what the dinas are so let's tell them
you're talking about your pasadena your
alt dina yeah your dina and deluca these
are places on the far east side
of the los angeles metropolitan area is
that true
i wouldn't say the far east side and the
greater scheme of things i've been to
sona's house
it took several days to get there three
boroughs died underneath me um it's way
way out there you're the far one
the greater community of this world here
that we live and work in lives on the
east where you live far on the west yeah
yeah
whose name is in the title of the show
friend rupert friend
jesus you're weird
what an odd fellow
okay
i'm as you know i'm a democratic man
and i believe in the power of different
voices
uh being raised and then um letting the
majority rule i've always felt that way
we're going to go to your house which is
in pasadena yeah and we're gonna be in
your backyard yeah i don't remember
there being a backyard well you haven't
been in it okay you came over one time
when we recorded that quarantine episode
and you guys came in the front door and
we recorded and you left the front door
right yeah back when people thought that
uh
coveted was going to be a thing yeah
back in those early paranoid days
two and a half years ago
anyway i do remember that
um
that was very strange because remember
we all gathered there and we thought
what is this what is this coveted thing
i guess if you gather in groups of like
five you can't get it this is early on
we didn't know anything about it this is
back when we were being told wipe down
all your groceries right because kovid
uh is spread by touching um a luck a box
of lucky charms that just came from a
ralph's like we didn't know anything no
and we didn't really touch each other
there are half of us there i kept trying
to touch you yeah that was part of the
reason we want to move this outside
but we wouldn't touch each other but
we'd be in the same room remember that
yeah and then it later turned out that
right that doesn't work
but
there were early days we didn't know
um and here we are now two and a half
years later and we're going to return to
your house
and triumph we're triumphant and we are
going to celebrate summer s'mores